hey guys welcome to another grooming
video here on dln
today it's all about the hair on your
legs
should men shave their legs or at least
trim it that's the question we're gonna
tackle today
let's not waste any more time let's get
to it
i have a dream that's all i need
i'll make it happen
all right now should men shave their
legs that's what i asked all of you guys
on my community page
i did a poll and you voted yes or no or
maybe just trim it now over 3500 people
voted and i'll give you the results at
the end of the video but first let me
give you
my opinion should men shave or trim
their legs well it depends on a few
things
let's start with the first one
[Music]
it depends on your girlfriend or your
wife
now you want to look good and attractive
for your partner right
right but not all women are the same
some say
just shave it all off some say no no
just trim it
just trim it and it'll look great and
some say don't touch
your hair women are different
men's journal ask 20 women how they feel
when men shave their legs and most of
them said it looks weird shaved
so just leave it and don't shave it
women's health on the other hand
ask their facebook followers the same
thing 49.3 percent said
it's weird guys shouldn't touch their
leg hair 28.5
said i don't like clean shaven but i do
appreciate a man who trims leg hair down
22.2 said it's awesome i love
a man with clean shaven legs so almost
80
of all women do not like clean shaved
legs and my wife is one of them
i also actually don't like it that much
but ask the woman
in your life what she likes
it depends on the sport or the work that
you do
now i'm a hairy guy and i'm fine with it
you know
but i have to shave my hair my leg hair
and also even my arms sometimes
for certain photo shoots it's also
better to shave your legs if you do
bodybuilding
to show muscle definition or if you do
cycling it's always better to get a post
right massage
with lotion and shaved legs compared to
hairy legs
and your hair won't get into open wounds
and cause
infection athletes also shave their legs
to lower the effect of drag
to speed up the recovery process of
wounds and some just do it to show their
muscles to look great
as an athlete
[Music]
it depends on the length of your hair
some guys got almost no hair and some
guys
got a little bit and then some guys they
got a lot of hair
and so they just trim it just to look a
little bit more normal and groomed
i'm not against that it's absolutely
your choice
if you want to look like a bushy
long-haired bear or if you just want a
well-groomed
look it's absolutely your choice
it depends on the effort look shaving
your legs clean
takes a lot of time and a lot of effort
to keep it
clean shaved a lot of people like myself
we just don't have the time to shave it
every single day or every second
day now trimming your hair a little bit
shorter with an electric trimmer
is a lot easier but keeping it shaved
all the time
that is a lot of work so i have a lot of
respect for women
because they just do it every day or
every second day
got a lot of respect for them
at the end of the day it's your choice
i personally i just leave my hair as it
is because i'm fine with it it's my hair
and this is who i am but this is what
you guys said when i asked you the same
question on my community page
should men shave their legs 11 said yes
39 said no 50
said maybe just trim it if it's very
long so
it's your choice do what works for you
shave it
trim it leave it it's your choice
and remember taking good care of
yourself
does not mean like some people say
you're vain you're puffed up you think a
lot about yourself
or you're gay like some people say it
just means
that you have enough respect for
yourself to take care
of yourself i'll see you guys in the
next video cheers